When someone says the EU,
many first think of Europe.
But this isn't entirely accurate.
The European Union has only 27 member states.
And even though some European countries have long,
rich histories with their EU cousins,
they've decided to remain outside of the union.
This is the case of Switzerland,
Norway, and Iceland.
But why are these three countries
so closely linked to a shared European identity?
Not part of the EU?
As always, let's take a look
at where these three countries are located on a map.
First up is Norway.
This Nordic nation sits right
the top of the Scandinavian Peninsula
with direct access to the North Sea,
the Arctic Circle
and the mouth of the Baltic Sea.
Norway borders with two EU members,
Finland and Sweden.
Second is Iceland.
Iceland is by far
the most isolated of the European nations,
with many map makers sadly forgetting to include it
in their sketches of the continent.
The closest EU neighbour is Ireland,
over 14 kilometers away.
Last, but not least
is Switzerland.
This is the country that many forget
isn't part of the EU,
as it sits right at the heart of the continent
and is surrounded by central EU states.
France, Germany,
Italy and Austria
all share a border with this Alpine haven.
Let's take a look at
each one's relationship with the union.